these are actually them so this is the
bag it's fresh it's an unboxing video
[Music]
you got your prospective be happy don't
you want to be happy
[Music]
[Music]
what's uh what's been the most knowing
how you how closely you followed me you
know what's been the thing that's most
surprised you like I keep that in mind
so I'm like you have so much other stuff
going on yeah you're you're doing all
the copy like you're you're doing the
context like you're doing it and so I
was surprised to see that I knew you
were involved but I figured it wasn't as
deep as you are and to see that and also
like you're literally communicating with
us it's a really interesting point
right which is Andy a lot of times talks
about like you need to talk more about
being smart or like things that nature
because because I don't talk about
certain things you're just you
everyone's just using it's not the
people are cynical or don't think I'm a
real guy I think people are just using
common sense to think it's impossible
because I don't think people realize
what the level of speed that I'm
actually talking about yeah it's a level
of like it's a level of speed that most
people aren't accustomed to so then you
can't think it's true because you think
you're going hard but you're also
spending an hour a day watching my
content I get it I get it
[Music]
like
yeah we can add more to it I don't like
anything no isn't a thing like that
yeah can you make it tighter I want this
thing as um as it goes I want my
signature Gary
all right this is it oh these are
actually them
this is the bag it's fresh just an
unboxing video is it man this is so [ __ ]
it I can't believe this
like the the video of like me coming up
with this idea in San Francisco on the
spot to this moment right now of the
flippity-flop do we do something back
here that just ludicrous to me one of
the things that like would be like for
example like it's really interesting
this just caught my eye right the second
the thought that there would be
something that you can then slide
something into is really rad to me like
I want to do something with if this is
gonna be like five it's the biggest shoe
I'm gonna make maybe ever for me just
because it's gonna matter to me the most
I mean my hand gesture you know most
back to like weird stuff like what if we
created something that hasn't happened
before like I love the idea I mean it's
really funny was that it just sat here
lovely idea
I think so very substantial yeah and
then and then it comes with like in the
pack five little things here and there
like a month later something comes out
that's exclusive for dollar 99 okay
Swiss to like put it in there like you
big you see where I'm going you know
it's pretty cool you sugar you know like
the that's such a cool video this is
[ __ ] cool man
[Music]
thank you brother
[Music]
lovely people like Gary you don't get
him like I can you get bro explain to me
why you shouldn't be living on your own
knees
can somebody make a video that counters
my point to why parents should be
quietly petting or publicly paying for
their kids like the [ __ ] comments I
get on DMS when this [ __ ] comes out it's
crazy
so Gary broke easy for you to say no no
not easy for me side so I lived on my
own TV I [ __ ] went further than that
I put them before my parents [ __ ] you
[ __ ]
well how am I supposed to live more
humbly don't own a house big shot that
you can't afford rent [ __ ]
seriously but how am i how am I supposed
to own a home but Gary how am I supposed
on home I'm like your mama [ __ ]
you haven't [ __ ] picking it out yet
you shouldn't do anything you don't want
that's like me saying why might not drop
in 55 points a game in the NBA cuz I'm
not doing it the reason you shouldn't
own the home dick face is cuz you
haven't saved money to buy a home
because that's the next part well
parents don't [ __ ] understand cuz I'm
in these covers you see them when you're
paying for them they're not saving
because you think they're red they're
buying Easy's Coachella and [ __ ]
drugs and well I see drugs
I mean $6 coffee for [ __ ] cocaine I
don't give a [ __ ] picket poor the drug
of I need to have the freshest clothes
to make pretend I'm flossing and win it
when I'm not earlier [ __ ]
save your feet be a [ __ ] grown up and
anything that doesn't do that leads to
insecurity you don't believe you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm in rare form
I feel good it's Jersey oh that was
really good by the way I think I should
only talk in New Jersey right [ __ ]
[Applause]
some real [ __ ]
[Applause]
[Music]
brother I don't know if there's a more
practical business maneuver than karma
look you know this we've run in enough
similar circles but I haven't spent time
reputation from people that have
actually spent time with you because by
the way there's people who think I must
think well salesman and I suck but
that's only because they're in a bad
place and they're not and they don't
know me
reputation from people that actually
know you is the entire currency
understand that you know what's really
funny really something there was a kid
they is ain't gon [ __ ] how close is he
like how long ago call him get him back
here five minutes late ale it was Satan
you were were you wait a minute he was
in the bathroom
what same were you in the bar you
pooping mark was just saying like it's
so interesting to me that you're more
genuine here than I see on video and I
was like it's funny you said that today
this kid Zayn who works for me and I was
looking for you who was like a superfan
engaged and everything like just was
like what was what's your biggest you've
been here what now to tell tell when I
asked you today what was your what was
the biggest thing that surprised you
what did you say
[Music]
like I you know I know that he was
involved but before I came you're like
you sure he's touching a little bit
reviewing it but he's like actually
all the context is creating the copy
like he's making it and I didn't expect
that and Mark what the punch of that
actually is like this whole game right
now like you on the outside but being
kind of team Gary too right now more to
him the basically here's the punch line
to Alex who's sitting up there
fundamentally this is how I judge
everybody and how I judge myself whoever
knows the most what do they think the
things I am singularly most proud of in
the world not a person knows yet
everybody thinks of a self-promoter um
I'm comfortable promoting business
that's business
the real humanity is quiet as [ __ ] so
great so just show me it in the video
don't worry about what you want worry
about what I want it nears this store
[Applause]
that's available towards exclusively
listen to me [ __ ] mixing up Russian
English that I can't believe you just
said that I was literally just pee
peeing and and trying to be cordial
munch ladies and I was like and I was
like this is the [ __ ] like honestly I
got to take this string off because it's
like covering the number sometimes like
I don't like strings in my hoodie's ever
I do a little bit good point game but I
don't like chewing on him show me three
to five variations of a the starting
point of the last video which didn't
have a sound by the way that I posted
was that my fault I thought so that's
why I enjoyed that moment
[Music]